I'm travel school I will be talking
about what's new in geometry
thank you for being here I'm going to
talk about what's new in geometry and
it's what we have been doing since the
last test conference to start
essentially I'm going to I mean the way
I break the talk was essentially in two
main part I'm going to talk about
usability because our main goal is
currently in geometry you know since you
know we're illegitimate so I think in
version 10 is to kind of improve and
make you know it more useable make it
easy to use and there's two part of that
one is you know the usability you know
improving and make it nice
from visualization and other aspect to
actually add new function or what you
expect to actually use you know as tools
in the system so I'm going to talk about
usability first and after that I'm going
to talk about functionality you know
what we added there's a kind of a mix
between but you know you're going to
kind of see the distinction and that we
kind of give you also the idea of where
we are going in long term because I kind
of like that you get that job where we
are going and then you're actually going
to see the big picture on how we we plan
to continue development and the last
part is also kind of the plan the future
you know all the different things I've
been doing as well as talking about the
other talks by team member here and
Angie bump if you want more details or
more specific topic okay usability first
okay so one thing you may have noticed
in the system for example like an image
there is an attached cell you know you
look at other object in the system where
you know you're actually able to really
like how the behave image or graph is
because if and automatically you know
they have at you know etosha formation
to it on social you can manipulate them
you know without actually having to do
the symbolic operation or
programmatically
you know stuff so what we try to do is
also to kind of add that in the geometry
and you can quite some work so we are
kind of progressively you know injecting
that to our
object so I'm going to first talk talk
about the attach cells so here we just
take a basic example of the bit oven I
should actually take a mesh way John Oh
so this is a mesh wedge on object we
just precise it so we get enough space
down stair so when you click on it you
know first you know the box is different
than normal graphic box but you will see
that you have an attached cell here
I believe we edit it in eleven point two
or so so what advantages you know there
is the usual behavior in graphic you can
rotate it manipulate it so that's one
one thing but in the attached cell you
kind of have an you know it's kind of a
contextual menu in an extended menu you
know specific for that no type of object
so you can press on it and directly you
have a you know a list of you know mesh
team you know you can take it look at
the you know wire frame for example the
list of line all you can put a smooth
shading on it so the whole thing is done
behind the scene we applied so you don't
really need to you know know the details
or sort but you can also go to the
documentation and see that or you can
take it and essentially you know add you
know the collation around it like in
this case a D you know the bounding box
or you can take it you know change the
orientation top bottom front back so
that kind of you know convenient so
that's that that usability we try to add
to the system
so you can just take your object or a
geometric object manipulate it look at
it visually do all the kind of things
you want so we hope to continue to
actually add it to more object in the
system at least in geometry graphic
object like that
and this actually work in you know 1d 2d
and 3d as usual we cover all dimension
on stuff so the 2d is also happy the
same but slightly different so you have
a specific title for the 2d on this set
of options in the 3d for example the
print part you know you can actually
directly connect to a 3d printer if the
object is printable or such and you also
have an information box which kind of
provide you a summary information about
the object
so it's kind of a delay valuation where
we compute it nicely so that was one
part in terms of you know usability you
know attach search it's kind of there
easily for you to manipulate the other
part is the Auto visualization so one
nice thing in general like I said before
is that when you have an object a graph
an image you know your important image
you see it that's nice a graph
evaluation it a random graph you see it
so you don't have your body till you are
happy that's kind of one usually
usability aspect which is important you
don't even think about if you don't
return you know a formal expression like
in this case you know a district you
know you get a disc right that doesn't
fit exactly with what we have like
earlier like in mesh where you know
usually you we evaluated mesh you
actually sees it so what we did in the I
think version 11.10 troduce region which
is a wrapper around your primitive in
this case I should actually write it
like this molecule wrapper so this is
actually also a natural region object
but if visualize like a disc so that
allows a sensor to do any kind of
operation on it you can take that region
and put it in area and then you have it
so for those object like graphic
primitive where we cannot change the
behavioral units have been there for
years
you know we introduced the wrapper
regions for that but one aspect of the
wrapper region so which actually does
kind of the intersection we fortunately
one aspect of the wrapper region is also
that it pays silver present on the line
set right so when you have a mesh region
right in the edge region effect in fact
is a the set of point plus in
description the partition of that that
region in space but sometimes you don't
actually want to look at that party so
you just want to manipulate the set of
point so one advantage of actually
having region is that is actually kind
of capris
that on the line structure part of the
region just to kind of slightly show you
that so if you take this mesh you know
the lineage we generate from your hand
set of random point is the mesh region
for example is true and is a region in
general but you can evaluate region you
can use the wrapper region around it you
see first that she lost that you know
meshing structure and if you even want
to check you can acts you know is it
actually a mesh region you and it's not
it's both so it's kind of the underlying
stuff you kind of you know forget about
the rest that's kind of the whole idea
we jump over to the two visualization
but it also kind of you know her present
a structure behind
and one of the creating also you have to
remember is that I mean the way I see
actually the geometry is that you know
we have the different constructors and
some of those constructor like national
is a whole there is a whole subsystem
around it right so you have you know by
subsist on a mini set of function which
actually work specially for that for
that set right and you have other one
which are just you know point set in
general and I'm making that you know
that main distinction because you know
I'm going to start to show actually some
of the function we introduced and we see
actually where the distinctions come
into place where actually the behavior
that actually mesh you know imply
certain type of behavior which in some
sense is not really mathematically
correct but it's useful when you're in
that subsystem so I'm going to talk
about you know Fujin Raijin and boolean
operation so that's kind of my
personality we actually stand it you
know this last this last release I think
11.2 so first of all we changed the
behavior of region intersession region
different region symmetry difference so
before he does operation we're returning
also a region intersection when they
were working on symbolic expressions so
now all of them return you a boolean
region so this is a basic example when
you do the regional intersection of two
discs you get actually boolean wage on
the boolean halogen is actually over
presentation we look at the region
intersection region difference as the
operation and has as we discussed
earlier I mean some of the people when
they see this they believed I mean the
thing that nothing actually happened if
you have the object region around it you
actually visually actually get the
result and this is kind of come back to
what I just talked a little bit earlier
is about Auto visualization we hope that
in the next future we are actually going
to do and we are going to make region
intersection or that boolean region Auto
visualized like that automatically even
though behind the scene is still that
that formal expression that symbolic
representation there so the hope is to
make you know introduce those
functionality as well as you know easy
to use our search but let's come back to
actually those boolean operations in
general so as I said when you have a
mesh region what we decided to do is
that when you parade them with you know
using a boolean function we kind of try
to her mean in that space of mesh we try
to preserve the mesh structure we try to
return you something valid for example
if you take in a region of intersection
of two mesh unless is a closed object
right closes you know intersection of
two closed object are closed obviously
or the Union but if you take the
difference of two closed object right a
disk on a disk they make the difference
you who move it you actually have an
open boundary in part of it right but in
the system currently if you do for
example region difference of two mesh we
are going to return you a mesh so
essentially we close it right if you
think topologically all like we say we
return the smallest boundary mesh which
contain that open object so we kind of
try to remain in that same subsystem so
a mesh result return you a message on a
boundary mesh we put on your boundary
mesh so that's kind of a big change and
we are going to push it in to most of
the operation we have like like
transform region will also return you of
a message or Estonia mesh wedge on a
search so if you are used to work with
mesh you are going to no feel at home
everything just work okay so in the same
direction so I want to kind of show you
some example here where we actually kind
of try to preserve those those behavior
so you take two expression here they are
kind of exact so three two triangles you
compute the region intersection so in
the case where we can actually represent
it with the the object we have in the
system you actually return you that
representation so if you manipulate
wrong
we hope to always return you a polygon
or something close to it you are
probably not going to return you a mesh
region so we kind of try to remain in
that same family or something more
general so you can take it and visualize
it so you have the two triangles
you enter said let me get a polygon and
same thing for implicit way John so you
have valid to imply implicit rejoined
you get an implicit way John and if you
use the way John Harper you actually get
the object visual either and if you take
you know to measure a John you evaluate
them you actually get a mesh when you
didn't get a formal expression you don't
get a polygon there even though the to
object you can think about it as two
polygons or two triangles essentially so
we kind of try to keep in that same same
family same structure and if you
manipulate you know derive region you
get another boolean operation since is
the region intersections and we can also
visualize it I will get the object there
in the object
okay
so I just want to shortly point out that
essentially in this release we actually
added boolean operation for 3d 3d
boolean operation essentially of a mesh
so this is just the standard list of you
know 1d we can do boolean operation is
just to segment in 2d which we had
before we actually enhance it you know
made it faster more stable and preserve
that you know subsystem return you will
and operation of a mesh return you a
mesh polygon will turn your polygons and
the 3d here I have two boundary mesh can
operate it and then get the boundary
mesh as I said before this is the region
difference right
in term of said Toria you know purely
this is not correct because you have a
boundary you have move that but since
they are measure between you an actual
measure is something to keep in mind
when you actually preview the system ok
so now I'm going to talk about the set
of you know other set of functionality
we added so one of one of the
functionality or one of the team which I
always to do is to give you know to make
bridge with other system right in the in
the language so one bridge is through
image processing so we have a fantastic
image processing so you can imagine you
take a mesh it handle has you know a
graphic which have like an image a
faster so what have you done is that you
can take a mesh and you can actually
pasteurize it you get actual the actual
raster using region image and you have
the other way around from an image you
can go and get image so I can take that
output and they can do image mesh and
then you get a mesh range on there so
you can go from an image in 1 in 2 or 3d
to a mesh and the other way around
so that's kind of a nice bridge if you
decide to to go under image consisting
of an image processing you decide to you
know use Michelle going
so one of the feature was also added was
Regent relations so we added region
equal so you can actually check if two
region are equals and so this also work
for all the family of the region we have
for mesh to graphic primitives or
special region has we call them so you
can check you know region disjoint like
in this example you take a triangle any
disc added each one we get to or you can
check you know is a region contained in
the other region so that's region within
so here are actually have a mix of an
implicit way John and analyst you can
use region within and in this case it
gave you actually should just in the in
this case you actually give you the
condition so behind the scene we
actually do also some symbolic
computation for the set of families as
well as support of assumption or sort so
that gonna work nicely
so I mean the list is long but we kind
of just you know hopefully stop here and
just tell you that you know we have been
essentially trying to improve the
framework make it faster make it better
you know the usability so it kind of
just naturally work for you you you know
you get what you expect right and in
long term we actually you know plan to
you know add some new additional sub
system like polygon and polygon with
holes or polygons Palio drawn poly tops
so that's something you you know you may
expect in the future so you actually
work on it and we also kind of
continuously improving boolean
operations so as you can imagine you
know in 2d 3d you know you kind of end
up with whole family of algorithm to
implement right if you implement line to
line intersection you know as such so we
are consciously working on it and trying
to improve it so some of the object
currently you you know you manipulate or
you do not get a boolean wedge on maybe
new next release you start to actually
return you inaudible presentation maybe
you know to value it to a bond animation
sort so we'll continue to kind of
improve that you know behind the scene
as well as the general performance so
that's pretty much it so I would like to
invite you to go to the exhibit
downstair we kind of have in geometry
lab or boot where we show you know the
interaction between geometric and
virtual reality we have our 3d printing
boots and the whole team is downstairs
for your question if you have any and
before I close I relied to kind of
invite you to the remaining to talk so
yesterday we gave a talk on unity link
and at 1:00 p.m. you have you know hands
on on unity or unity link so if you want
to go on you know really learn and play
with unity link you know stop by bring a
laptop and tomorrow yarn we'll be
talking about geometric modeling so
that's an aspect I haven't really talked
here because you should go there she
will show you all the new cost Otto we
have you know as well as you know how
you can you know play with boolean
we currently have how you can actually
build models on something concrete and a
bomb also we'll talk about I will try to
help you or give you idea how to you
know solve your problem using the
functionality we have in the system so
thank you
[Applause]